[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Jacky vanov étaithnologue il est
spécialiste des nomades marins d'Asie du
Sud-Est plus connus sous le nom de
mocken
quelques mois avant son départ pour la
Birmanie il décide de se replonger dans
les images filmées par son père décédé
chez les moquens en 1973
en plus de leur valeur ethnologiques ces
vieilles bobines de films sont un
avant-goût de ce qui attend Jacques sur
un terrain d'étude qui n'a pas changé
depuis 50 ans
ces images du passé ne peuvent faire
oublier que la Birmanie d'aujourd'hui
reste un pays gouverné par des
militaires et l'un des derniers
territoires fermés du monde contemporain
[Musique]
mon père Pierre Ivanov était ethnographe
plutôt on va dire explorateur
aventuriers à faire des films des livres
et des circuits de conférence
qui est parti chez les moquettes pour un
terrain de un an et demi de 18 mois il
essayait de pénétrer la Birmanie en
dépit toutes les difficultés et il est
mort d'ailleurs à la frontière et en
fait c'est simplement un assassinat pour
lui voler son matériel qui était à
l'époque assez important
les moquens sont des nomades marins et
navigue en flotti de 8 à 10 bateaux dans
l'archipel Mergui 800 îles au large de
la Thaïlande et surtout de la Birmanie
donc 3000 individus répartis en
plusieurs sous-groupes
je suis devenu ethnologue
simplement en allant voir les moquer de
même en 81 pour des raisons familiales
on va dire parce que j'ai voulu aller
voir où était mort mon père mais je suis
resté avec eux parce que dès la première
année
j'ai bien compris que j'étais fait pour
m'entendre avec eux parce que c'est des
nomades inconsciemment j'avais compris
que ils étaient libres que c'était les
derniers à pouvoir vivre dans la
contradiction perpétuelle dans un monde
qui bougeait et qui allait pas
s'améliorer c'est là dessus qu'on s'est
entendu
j'ai jamais remis en cause leur mode de
vie je me suis tout de suite adapté pour
moi cette année tout de suite c'est
après que j'ai compris que on était fait
pour être ensemble et c'est pour ça que
je les défends toujours et que je
défendrai encore
[Musique]
Jacques Ivanov a reçu en héritage les
travaux de son père il décide après 23
ans d'études sur les moquens d'organiser
une ultime expédition à travers les eaux
interdites de l'archipel de Mergui
c'est 28 jours en mer ont pour finalité
une exposition sur la culture moquaine à
Rangoon capitale de la Birmanie alors
que Jacques négocie les dernières
autorisations auprès de la jungle
birmane à l'autre bout du pays ses
collaborateurs s'attelent au dernier
préparatifs où sont les ustensiles pour
la cuisine
ils sont avec la glacière ah ok je vois
et tu es sûr qu'on a tout
oui on va tout ranger en bas tu es sûr
qu'on l'a hein
ah ça c'est bien ça c'est bien ça c'est
bien ok pour cette année on est presque
tous là tous les mêmes membres de
projets sont là mais quand on n'est pas
encore là donc il faut attendre on ne
sait pas il nous disent aujourd'hui mais
probablement ça serait demain parce que
si il est parti
donc qui peut parler avec les personnes
militaires même
lui il est pratiquement l'assistant de
dimonai le responsable du MTT
ils savent même pas si le bateau est
parti s'il n'est pas parti donc on
comprend pas et nous on peut rien faire
qu'attendre on essayera il y a Jacques
déjà qu'il y a Rangoon donc si le bateau
va pas arriver il faut prendre le
contact avec les autorités les
militaires et leur dire écoutez il faut
que nous partes dites nous où est le
bateau parce qu'en fait nous maintenant
on a aucune idée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans un pays où l'uniforme militaire
fait loi les communications ne sont pas
chose facile pourtant les nouvelles sont
prometteuses le bateau devra arriver
dans les 24 heures reste à la charge de
Jacques d'obtenir les dernières
autorisations spéciales pour prendre la
mer
oui
très bien et la date de l'exposition ça
reste toujours le 19 avril
ok donc demain matin quand tu viens le
bateau va être encore derrière dans le
port on va régler ça ok à demain salut
c'est toujours très compliqué ici c'est
demain oui puis de maintenant c'est
après-demain ça peut durer des journées
jusqu'en trouve vraiment ce qu'on
cherche un bateau par exemple ça peut
tarder des fois deux trois jours cette
fois ça fait déjà 5 jours qu'on a pas de
bateau
[Musique]
enfin s'annonce en rade de Victoria
point le futur bateau de l'expédition il
sera baptisé le Moken Queen
au sein d'une dictature la certitude
n'est la meilleure alliée de personnes
[Musique]
le cargo flambant neuf promis par les
autorités n'est plus qu'un vieux Rafio
rafistolet
l'inquiétude semble gagner Luca et
Marcello devant le fait accompli ils
échafaud déjà leur plan pour aménager le
confort minimum nécessaire au périple
chose courante en Birmanie pour
d'obscures raisons les militaires ont
sûrement réquisitionné le bateau prévu
avant de le remplacer par une épave
[Musique]
ne fonctionne pas sur la prise de
courant mais en mer j'en ai besoin tout
le temps
avant de partir il faut absolument
trouver une batterie
vous avez dit que c'était un bateau
nouveau qu'il avait un an je crois pas
c'est un bateau je crois que comme
l'autre bateau a été confisqué par les
militaires et ils ont tout de suite donc
aujourd'hui il y aura une bonne journée
de travail
est-ce que vous pouvez débarrasser tout
ce qui encombre l'arrière vous pouvez
faire ça comme ça on pourra installer un
plastique sur le toit
[Musique]
l'arrivée du bateau est une première
étape les derniers problèmes logistiques
doivent encore être réglés il est
maintenant nécessaire d'aménager cet
espace restreint destiné à accueillir
les 8 marins birements ainsi que les
membres de l'expédition aucun
ravitaillement n'est prévu durant les
quatre semaines d'exploration à travers
les 800 îles de l'archipel
vivre et eau potable doivent donc être
embarqués en quantité suffisante
[Musique]
les cales seront remplies de barils de
gasoil les intermédiaires locaux en font
payer 4 fois le prix c'est le sésame
pour obtenir un combustible de qualité
[Musique]
les autorisations en poche Jacques
arrive de Rangoon il peut maintenant
commencer les cours parler avec les
autorités locales
chaque île chaque trajet chaque arrêt
doit être négocié les militaires
imposent au bateau de naviguer à plus de
20 000 marins des côtes
la gourmandise du représentant du
ministère du Tourisme birman et sans
borne faire preuve de diplomatie ne
suffit plus
[Musique]
la corruption est à peine dissimulée les
dessous de table en billets verts de
préférence certes à monnaie et les
autorisations les visas le bateau et les
salaires de l'équipage
on va aller là où je voulais aller on
peut y aller ce qui m'intéresse le plus
on peut
faire le nom parce que le propriétaire
il va pas être d'accord
[Musique]
tu as une marge de manœuvre une journée
ou deux entre l'itinéraire autorisé
ça fait 5 passagers à 120 dollars par
passager pour les papiers ce qui nous
fait donc 700 dollars
[Musique]
alors que les membres de l'expédition
achève la préparation du cargo Jacques
décide de retourner à l'endroit où il
fit ses premiers pas en Birmanie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une fois les offrandes bouddhistes
d'usage effectués le Moken Queen peut
enfin prendre la mer l'expédition est
partie pour 28 jours de navigation
Jacques a réussi à négocier la première
partie de son périple il est assuré de
pouvoir explorer les eaux du Sud de la
Birmanie ce parcours précis à travers
les îles de l'archipel amènera le Moken
Queen jusqu'à Mergui
[Musique]
on part pour faire cette exposition à
yangungun on doit collecter le maximum
d'objets moquens et le transporter dans
la capitale c'est quand même 2000 km du
nord au sud avec le problème majeur que
aucun bateau ne peut aller du nord au
sud donc il faut une autorisation qu'on
a toujours pas donc pour l'instant on
focalise sur collecter les objets et
puis on verra bien ne serait-ce que ça
c'est déjà pas facile
[Musique]
après deux jours de mer et 120 km
parcourus les signes avant-coureurs
d'une présence moquette se font enfin
sentir
il peut faire tout le tour et chercher
si tu sais pas qui peuvent être cachés
par là tu passes 4 fois devant comme on
a fait rien non non c'est là-bas
il y a une petite anse là qui est juste
derrière l'île et c'était pas si tu sais
pas tu peux pas les voir
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est un vieux mot d'origine
d'austrodésienne donc c'est comme ça
aussi que tu sais à peu près d'où ils
viennent celui-là est vieux il a été
remis en plan chez réparé plusieurs fois
il est
avec un gouvernail central ce qui n'est
pas du tout
traditionnel ceci c'est parce qu'il a un
moteur assez puissant ça c'est l'avant
les champs creux avant ça s'appelle la
bouche qui mange ça sert de
marche-pied pour les plongeurs mais ça
rappelle aussi au mocken que non
seulement ils mangent par la mer mais
que tout ce qui mange ils doivent le
rejeter à l'arrière donc c'est pour ça
s'appelle la bouche qui mange et
l'arrière l'arrière qui défèque ceci dit
c'est très pratique pour les marche-pied
et tous les termes c'est des termes même
quand ils construisent tu as les joues
du bateau tu as le cou tu as le ventre
tout ça a une c'est anthropomorphe
toutes les toutes les parties du bateau
sont
[Musique]
basés sur le corps humain
tout est en train de se transformer tout
le monde a dit c'est fini les moquettes
se terminaient
moi je les vois ici comme il y a 20 ans
c'est exactement la même ambiance tu as
le même feeling avec ces gens-là
bon les nanas sont assez dynamiques et
marrante elles sont pas trop
paranoïaques enfin l'année dernière
quand on est monté sur un bateau comme
ça les filles ont hurlé tout de suite tu
vois donc ils sont quand même qu'il y a
encore ces vieilles traditions de rap de
viol pillage et tout ça qui reste mais
je trouve que l'un dans l'autre ils
tiennent bien le choc
afin de reprendre pied sur son terrain
Jacques décide de négocier l'achat de
coquillages à la manière moquette
et si je prends tout tu me demandes
combien
tu peux pas tu vois la difficulté que tu
poses à moteur je lui demande combien tu
me les vends incapable de répondre ils
sont tellement habitués à ce que les
choses soient dans son saveur
amitié voilà j'en prends que la moitié
et là combien
non nous on ne peut pas accepter
d'argent
[Musique]
et moi maintenant je suis tout triste à
cause de vous
voilà
combien pour tout ça et avec la nacre
non on a rien d'autre à te vendre
et qui d'autre peut m'en avoir
pourquoi tu comptes pas ce qu'il prend
de compter il ne sait pas compter
vous êtes riche non nous sommes pauvre
je lui dis c'est pas vrai il y a deux
moteurs
[Musique]
au sein de la société moquens l'argent
n'a aucune valeur en dehors de tout
système économique une flottille reste
reliée au monde extérieur par le biais
d'un personnage essentiel le Toquet
il est l'intermédiaire Birmant au
chinois qui vient acheter le fruit de
leurs collectes principalement constitué
de coquillages et de mollusques séchés
la transaction est de courte durée si
tôt l'argent en main les moquens
s'empressent de le dépenser pour
acquérir les produits de première
nécessité riz cigare alcool et
maintenant donne-moi du bétel des
feuilles de bétel alors immédiatement
ça c'est provision de survie pour les
femmes
[Musique]
et ça tu me le vends pour combien
ah non c'est trop cher je ne peux pas te
le prendre
ils ont tous une île de résidence
principale
où ils se mettent à la saison des pluies
pendant 400 mois
ils font la cérémonie c'est une
cérémonie de réunion et après la saison
sèche là pendant la nôtre il s'éclate en
flottille parce que c'est des airs de
nomadisme pour collecter et la flotti
c'est en fait c'est des familles
étendues ici le bateau c'est une famille
nucléaire là d'ailleurs tu as le
prototype de la famille moquette
marie-fam deux enfants et il y a
toujours un vieux donc en fait la
moyenne que j'ai fait c'est 5 par bateau
ce qui correspond à peu près
[Musique]
ils sont très sympas avec les enfants en
plus
sont très monogames ils sont très filés
très amoureux les mecs s'occupent
beaucoup des enfants
[Musique]
c'est pour ça que vivre dans une
flottise c'est très sympa parce que les
relations amoureuses sont vachement
stables
[Musique]
non c'est très très difficile
psychologiquement parce que c'est des tu
vois bien je veux dire tu passes 2h avec
eux je veux dire que tu es quand même
psychologiquement mais c'est justement
cette différence entre eux et moi qui
fait que ça te remettait tellement en
question que tu étais ouvert tu deviens
complètement ouvert à la différence ce
qu'est la valeur de l'éthologie exotique
pour moi c'est pour ça que j'ai toujours
fait une différence avec les taux
exotiques elle existe parce que tu as
une différence et c'est cette différence
qui te fait comprendre parce que tu te
remets en cause et puis les autres aussi
et du coup dans le tu vois au milieu de
tout ça il se passe en échange je les
comprendrais jamais à 100% c'est sûr
mais je comprendrais plus parce que j'ai
un regard éloigné c'est une vieille
tradition avec logique qu'on équilibre
plus du tout à la mode ça ne se fait
plus maintenant tu vas étudier ton
voisin de palier mais tu vois l'exotique
bon c'est bon pour les médias or je
pense que c'est une erreur gravissime la
bonne éthologie est une éthologie
exotique
[Musique]
moi j'ai déjà vu ça et c'est pour pas
casser le bon bout des fois le même
parallèle
[Musique]
semaine après son départ l'expédition
arrive en vue d'une crique où les
moquens seraient susceptibles de se
réunir
Jacques et ses collaborateurs partent
sur le terrain en éclaireur
[Musique]
ça a été
défricher là-bas et planter de je sais
pas quoi il était quand même là il y a
tous les paquets de coquillages qui
mangent et tout
[Musique]
après avoir fait le tour de Lille Jack
et Marcello découvre que les moquens ont
bien ses journées sur place une
cérémonie aux esprits a eu lieu les
traces du rituel en latex
[Musique]
l'expédition a manqué les nomades de
quelques jours la découverte de cet
endroit n'en reste pas moins
exceptionnelle
[Musique]
militaires virement ils vont dire c'est
bien et
ça c'est du bouddhisme c'est des
offrandes complètement
bouddhistes au fond ils ont gardé leur
petit hôtel le fameux papa de foot
tu vois que les enfants principales
alcool
et puis là tu mets des bougies pour
allumer quand tu danses autour de des
poteaux aux esprit tu vois tout l'alcool
qui appartèrent pas d'alcool pas de fête
incroyable
alors il me dit que c'est pour appeler
le vent tu vois tous les tissus blancs
qui bougent ça veut dire que les esprits
arrivent que donc on va pouvoir entrer
en France ce qui va appeler les esprits
par l'intermédiaire de ces drapeaux et
les hélices et elles ont la même
fonction c'est pour le vent
des moquettes sont un peuples de
l'entre-deux c'est à dire qu'ils sont ni
des marins de haute mer ni des
forestiers ils se sont trouvés une niche
écologique qui est entre la terre et la
mer et là tu vois les limites là c'est
la limite de la marée étale et là c'est
la limite c'est les front des autres on
va juste derrière tu as la forêt qui
commence donc ils sont ni forêt ni mer
ils se sont trouvés un entre deux c'est
des collecteurs de tu restrans ou des
collecteurs de plastique qui ramassent
tout ce qui trouve dans cette dans cet
internat
[Musique]
une flotte immokens se présente à
l'horizon
Jacques prépare son assistant Marcello à
un premier contact avec les nomades il
sera en charge de ramener à bord un
poteau aux esprits pièce maîtresse de
l'exposition
on en est dans la période les jeunes
prennent leur relais la génération
suivante prend le relais donc le firs
contact je vais lui laisser ce qui est
toujours quand même le plus grand
plaisir de l'éthologue même si c'est le
plus paniquant là il en est à 150 là son
cœur là
en fait c'est pas du tout ça la raison
c'est que j'ai pas envie d'y aller j'ai
peur donc je l'envoie
[Rires]
j'arrive pas à faire des compliments
j'ai confiance en toi
j'ai une technique
qui a rodé depuis 15 ans mais maintenant
j'aimerais bien que Marcello tu vois se
prennent ce premier contact et arrive à
gérer les situations moquelles ce qui
est pas facile donc là mon idée c'est de
l'envoyer avec dessous notre guide qui
parle en anglais rudimentaire de faire
traduire en moquette et comme Marcello
parle un peu moquens quand même il sera
déjà si la traduction est bonne ou pas
s'il est forcera à faire attention aux
je pense que c'est une bonne technique
pour qu'il apprenne
[Musique]
où se trouve les poteaux aux esprits
là-bas là-bas derrière la pointe de
l'île
j'ai moqué une vive sur des bateaux mais
que 6 mois par an c'est une saison des
pluies quand même donc c'est vraiment
sur le bateau qui s'épanouit
un bateau c'est une maison donc une
famille nucléaire donc il y a déjà une
osmose entre le bateau et la famille
entre le repérage du bois et la finition
du bateau il faut compter deux saisons
une bonne saison des pluies où ils sont
à terre ils peuvent travailler et puis
une saison sèche où ils reviennent de
temps en temps voilà donc c'est un
travail c'est le plus gros travail
c'est vraiment de voir c'est comme si je
vois naître la culture moquette c'est à
partir de là que tout commence
on a des maladies mais nous n'avons ni
les médecines ni les aiguilles pour se
soigner alors du coup ceux qui sont
malades et bien ils meurent très vite
aborder une flottille moquette c'est pas
facile c'est quand même des gens qui
sont farouches très inquiets qui peuvent
partir en trois secondes or on est quand
même en Asie et les Asiatiques savent
très bien gérer des relations quand
elles sont cadrées
dans quelque chose qui leur convient
alors je sais que les moquens ont une
relation patron client très forte et
c'est là-dessus que je joue tu vois
d'abord je joue sur le mot quand je leur
gueule dessus c'est j'arrive je disais
mais je leur dis mais pourquoi vous
passez votre temps à jouer aux cartes et
rien faire vous êtes une bande de
feignants ça les fait rigoler d'abord
parce qu'il engueulant ils savent que je
parle moquens première chose que je sais
leur humour donc tout de suite tu vois
il y a la formation circuit
immédiatement dans la fatigue quoi et
puis il y a aussi que j'ai pas beaucoup
de temps donc c'est vrai que j'y vais un
peu en direct
à travailler vous me racontez toujours
des histoires pour dire que vous ne
savez rien faire
mais en voyant ça les Birmans ils vont
se dire oh là là ils savent bien
travailler les moquens ils savent bien
faire les choses
[Musique]
donne-moi tes verres pour que je vois de
plus près
j'espère que ça va être mieux maintenant
est-ce que quelqu'un peut venir avec moi
pour construire des maquettes pour moi
le poteau esprit qui est là-bas c'est
quelqu'un d'ici
et quelqu'un peut venir avec moi pour
faire une copie une copie de ce poteau
là
c'est juste pour voir je voudrais voir
un peu comment vous faites pour
travailler d'accord
allez prenez une hache on y va
là il répare le bateau qui a été cassé
qu'on voulait montrer à l'exposition je
lui ai demandé de le refaire parce qu'il
devait m'en faire un l'année dernière et
il l'a pas fait donc en échange je lui
ai demandé de me réparer souvenirs
mais c'est le principe des vieux tu vois
c'est ce qu'on appelle lui c'est le
responsable du groupe mais en fait il
peut pas faire bouger un de ses mecs il
a aucun pouvoir toute la société
moquette ça repose là dessus c'est cassé
le pouvoir du vieux sauf pendant les
rituels à chaque fois que je lui demande
mais envoie un mec coupé du bois tu vois
non non c'est pas possible demande-lui
démerde-toi
[Musique]
[Rires]
quand on est venu la première fois ici
ils m'ont reconnu ils savaient déjà que
j'étais
l'occidental qui travaillait à kossouris
avec les weekends c'est à dire que
l'information que j'existe elle est
montée jusqu'à une île qui s'appelle
bentic c'est à dire encore une centaine
de kilomètres au nord ils connaissent
mon existence
il pense être des grands chasseurs je
les ai souvent vu partir chasser ils ont
jamais rien ramener mais
dans leur imagination il reste des
chasseurs en fait c'est des
chasseurs-cueilleurs qui ont été poussés
à la mer plus ou moins donc c'est ce
qu'on les appelle les chasseurs de la
merde
c'est pour ça qu'ils ont des harpons qui
chassent les tortues et des choses comme
ça et qui sont pas d'outils de pêche ils
ont que des outils de chasse
[Musique]
la quête d'objets n'a pas été
miraculeuse heureusement un poteau aux
esprits enrichira quand même
l'inventaire scientifique
mais les moquens ne peuvent pas se
séparer de ce symbole spirituel sans le
rite d'usage
ils improvisent exceptionnellement une
réplique de leur cérémonie sacrée
[Musique]
alors nous étions là hier soir demain
nous irons par là et on voit s'il y a
des moquets on s'arrête sinon on
continue tout droit par là
et demander aux pêcheurs du poisson pour
ce soir sinon on aura rien à manger
les autorités ont décidé de regrouper
tous les cinq sous groupe moquens ici
ils leur ont dit vous passerez la saison
des pluies ici donc il reconstruit des
petites maisons en fonction des
sous-groupes et on avait demandé à
chaque sous-groupe de nous faire
20 objets traditionnels
donc normalement on devrait ressortir
avec 80 objets mon calcul est que si on
en a 30% ce sera déjà énorme voilà
on a vu des politiques de séparation
ethniques et très virement on trouve
partout en Birmanie c'est pas spécifique
ici comme c'est des îles tu vois une
séparation sur une petite île ça
ressemble plus à un camp qui a une
séparation donc c'était au nom de la
préservation des races et c'est vendu
uniquement pour le bien des moquettes
la maison
du
salon
est-ce qu'il peut rentrer chez vous
vous avez donné de l'argent pour
fabriquer des objets est-ce que vous
savez où ils sont
vas-y demande-lui toi si tu parles en
birman ça lui fera moins peur alors tu
lui demandes si son mari a fait quelque
chose pour nous
madame l'année dernière on a commandé
des lances et des maquettes de bateaux
au chef du village elles sont pour nous
ou celle qu'on a vu dehors
voilà la femme du chef qui vient
d'arriver
non je ne suis pas au courant il n'a
rien laissé
on a vu la maquette de bateau dehors
elle n'est pas pour nous non je ne sais
pas
moi j'ai laissé plein de choses et
beaucoup d'argent à ton mari l'année
dernière pour qu'il travaille pour nous
maintenant il reste plus rien il n'a
rien laissé on avait commandé des fois
mdr pour un tortue ah bon tout ça
et oui tout ça
des maquettes de bateaux
les maquettes de bâtons ne les a plus
c'est les Birmans qui ont tout pris et
nous là il ne nous reste plus rien mais
on t'avait quand même donné des choses
l'année dernière va voir le nouveau chef
oui je vais aller le voir parce que
quand même j'ai donné beaucoup d'argent
il a été remplacé par un virement ce
dernier ne semble pas enclin à
comprendre les attentes de l'expédition
les explications sont des plus confuses
en une journée Jacques a tout entendu
les moquettes n'ont pas travaillé ils
ont dépensé l'argent les Birmans ont
volé les objets pour finir un petit
seigneur local amateur d'art à 16h les
conserveraient à des fins personnelles
il aurait même la volonté de monter son
propre musée ethnique toutes ces
histoires laisse à Jacques peu d'espoir
quant à la possibilité de récupérer les
objets
conscient de se trouver dans une réelle
impasse il décide de passer à la vitesse
supérieure
ok pour le moment on ne peut rien faire
mais ce qu'il nous faut maintenant
absolument pour l'exposition tu vas leur
expliquer que l'on doit aller à Rangoon
faire une exposition on a besoin
d'objets et pour ça on va aller faire un
tour et voir si des choses nous
intéressent si c'est le cas on demande
l'autorisation et on les prend
beaucoup plus court
qui sont partis je ne sais où on va
chercher
et j'ai proposé de les acheter donc on
va aller voir les propriétaires
avant de remonter sur le bateau les
membres de l'expédition croisent un
virement disposés à leur venir en aide
miraculeusement ce nouvel intermédiaire
promet à Jacques les objets commandés
pour le lendemain
alors les vases le coupe coupe celui-là
aussi
[Musique]
coup de théâtre au petit matin l'état
d'urgence militaire et décrété au
village l'armée ne veut pas de regard
gênant sur ces trafics de marchandises
et de main d'oeuvre personne ne sera ce
qui se passe sur place mis à part les
habitants de punala
le Mooken Queen est contraint de
reprendre la mer sans espoir de
récupérer le moindre objet
ultime tentative le guide officiel de
l'expédition chochou va tenter de
convaincre les autorités de le laisser
récupérer les objets promis la veille
ces seuls atouts face aux militaires
sont les multiples autorisations
tamponnées signées et contre signé par
les plus hautes sphères de Rangoon
depuis le début il nous interdisent
d'aller à droite
il nous donne une heure d'autorisation
et en fait le village est très riche par
rapport aux autres donc je pense que
c'est une plaque tournante locale
en plus c'est pas loin de gargouilles
[Musique]
militaire on vient de perdre tous nos
matériels qu'on a payé 200000
chats l'année passée
et on peut pas revenir sur cette île car
le temps est limité donc il faut aller
vers le nord un peu plus redescendre le
sud
[Musique]
une flotte immoca isolée croise au large
du Nil Jacques compte bien profiter de
cette rencontre inattendue pour enrichir
son exposition de quelques pièces
[Applaudissements]
alors il y a des malades parmi vous
bon il faut prendre les médicaments que
je vais vous donner un le matin et un le
soir
le taux de mortalité infantile c'est un
sur deux c'est 50% l'espérance de vie
comme je te l'avais dit 40 ans
et après il résiste comme papy une page
en papier 40 ans c'est bon ATP
alors un le matin et ça ira mieux
c'est joli ça c'est un jouet pour les
enfants non ça a été fabriqué par les
enfants
je vous l'achète 10004 vous êtes
d'accord
non non
chat
il vous propose 1000 chats et vous ne
les prenez pas vous êtes vraiment
stupide
[Musique]
ils ne veulent pas me le vendre
elle est très jolie ta natte là tu me la
vends quoi la nappe
d'accord
il faut que je demande à ma femme
[Musique]
d'accord alors demande-lui d'en faire
une nouvelle et puis qu'elle me vend de
la vieille d'accord
il veut nous acheter la natte tu es
d'accord toi mais si tu es d'accord on a
qu'à lui vendre
[Musique]
nous reviendrons
il faut éviter d'avoir à traverser ce
secteur la nuit
[Musique]
quand on sera sur place on pourra
décider de gagner Lille rocher
[Musique]
les
îles sisters sont une étape importante
prévue dès le départ de l'expédition ces
deux îlots paradisiaques abritent
traditionnellement plusieurs Flottis
moquens ils servent de pied-à-terre au
nomade pendant la saison des pluies
[Musique]
tu vois les petites caïdes de droite
c'est toutes des moquettes et puis à
gauche c'est des virements de plus en
plus poussés
il y a des petites pagodes que tu vas
voir tu vois il y a du poisson qui sèche
partout
toutes les femmes moquaient elles sont
en train de ramasser le poisson des
pêcheurs Birmant ça va devenir un
village de pêcheur birman
c'est la partie supérieure
[Musique]
moi j'en ai mangé déjà
c'est vraiment pas bon
les ailerons de requin c'est ça qui vaut
le plus cher forcément le marché chinois
avec les eaux de curry et puis le
poisson séché bon bah écoute c'est des
choses qui se vendent dans tout
l'archipel parce que ça se conserve pour
les pêcheurs
[Musique]
tout est fonction de la marée là on est
en plein dans les plus grandes marées tu
vois les estrans découverts au maximum
ici encore c'est pas terrible mais des
fois tu as un kilomètre même voire deux
kilomètres destrant coralliens ou
sableux
et pendant c'est la grande période
d'activité de collecte donc mes
collègues vers de ça
en fait tout ce qui se trouve les
coquillages les des bénitiers
tout ce qui trouve quoi c'est des
collecteurs c'est leur activité
principale
et quand c'est la période des grandes
marées comme ça c'est très difficile de
défaire travailler parce qu'ils feront
tout en fonction de la marée
c'est là que c'est des collecteurs
est-ce que tu ne peux absolument pas
leur faire changer leur système de vie
aucun prétexte à part les armes
évidemment mais sinon tu pourras pas les
faire bouger si c'est la période des
grandes marées
[Musique]
je suis resté avec eux pendant longtemps
ce que tu vois sur ces images ils sont
tous morts
e
dont je m'occupais
il voit toute sa culture passer en
bouquin il veut se dire tiens
alors maintenant on va faire un autre
livre et cette fois c'est vous qu'on
mettra dedans ça te fait pas peur non
là sur cette photo ce sont des énigmes
vous en avez ah oui oui quand il n'y a
plus de Rio on mange ça
[Musique]
normalement c'est attaché la pointe est
attachée au
harpon et le harpon est attaché au
bateau
donc quand il lance le truc il y a la
pointe qui se détache avec la tortue le
harpon qui flotte et le harcon est
maintenu au bateau
[Musique]
tu vois bien que c'est un bateau du
vieux quoi du potao parce qu'il est
quand même très bien rangé il est assez
propre
c'est le chamane et comme je vous disais
tu vois les croyances worken c'est un
joyeux melting pot de un peu tout et là
c'est quand même très bouddhiste
[Musique]
aucune notion du temps une notion de
l'argent très limitée quand tu veux
travailler avec eux c'est le prototype
du sauvage en accord avec la nature il a
pas d'argent il a pas de temps mais
quand tu vis avec eux je veux dire tu
vis là-dedans tes impératifs ils te
viennent immédiatement en général
donc tout ce qui est difficile à vivre
en Occident de te revient d'une violence
extrême quoi tu te demandes pourquoi il
faut aller chercher des visas tu te
demandes pourquoi il faut aller
s'emmerder à faire 50 000 papiers et qui
parient complètement inutiles et eux ils
arrivent à passer entre les mailles du
filet et je suis fait encore moins
fasciné par leur manière de survivre en
Birmanie parce que quand même tu vois
c'est pas facile et il y a une pression
quand même énorme de des militaires et à
chaque fois ils arrivent à s'en sortir
il déplace il se regroupent il s'éclate
il se remettent ensemble ce qui fait que
tu arrives jamais véritablement à les
attraper sur un truc mais c'est ça qui
me plaît aussi moi je suis pareil il y a
des fois je passe pas les informations
je m'en vais c'est assez difficile de
travailler avec moi pour ça quoi et il y
a une manière de choses que j'ai appelé
leur bulles sociales c'est à dire qu'ils
se protège complètement de l'extérieur
même quand les Birmans arrivent pour
regarder ce qu'ils font et cetera il y a
une position d'attentiste
de force d'inertie qui se met en marche
ou je sens maintenant
qui est terrible qui est terrible je
dirais même les Birmans ils n'arrivent
pas à le casser donc c'est pour moi les
derniers hommes libres oui c'est après
il y en a plus quoi
[Musique]
et les couleurs c'est le matin c'est un
peu compliqué et la symbolique des trucs
vraiment limitée c'est des fleurs ou des
habits
mais c'est pas lui d'ailleurs quand même
bien décidé dans ses choix
[Musique]
ça représente le canal de communication
avec les ancêtres et les figures sont
particulières à chaque sous-groupe lui
là il a fait une copie des photos
esprits de ce village là
quand tu
fais bouger le drapeau ça veut dire que
les esprits arrivent et tous les
officiers sont en bas et ils sont en
transe ils reçoivent les esprits les uns
après les autres
[Musique]
une fois les objets chargés à bord le
temps est venu de quitter les nomades
des îles sisters
les membres de l'expédition insistent
pour se faire photographier avec les
moquens autour des objets fabriqués le
chaman se prête au jeu c'est pour lui
une façon de sacraliser la séparation
avec le poteau aux esprits que ses mains
en sculptées
[Musique]
les cales sont pleines grâce à la
coopération de la flottie moquette les
îles sisters ne sont pas un endroit
facile à quitter le mot Ken Queen doit
néanmoins rallier Mergui au plus vite
les autorisations de naviguer expirent
dans deux jours
[Musique]
le mocan Queen a quitté la pointe sud de
la Birmanie depuis bientôt 4 semaines
lorsque Mergui arrive en vue
ce port est le centre névralgique de la
région il est également au cœur des
préoccupations de Jacques
l'enjeu est de taille tout le travail
entrepris dépend de cet état
le cargo est surtout sa précieuse
cargaison d'objets moquens doivent
arriver à Rangoon 1000 km plus au nord
pourtant aucun occidental n'a été
autorisé à effectuer ce trajet depuis le
départ de Birmanie des colons anglais
industrie plutôt
les bases militaires secrètes les
gazodes du quai autreléoduc délimitent
cette région interdite en plein golfe du
Bengale jusqu'à très récemment une
plaque tournante du trafic de l'héroïne
et de l'opium
à l'heure actuelle l'expédition ne
dispose pas du laisser passer pour
quitter Mergui
le guide désigné par l'administration
birmane est chargé d'obtenir le sésame
vers la voie maritime cet enjeu éclipse
quelque peu l'excitation de toucher
terre
d'habitude on est toujours agité comme
des poux quand on arrive à Merville tout
le monde se prépare ce beau et en 5
minutes tout le monde s'est barré parce
que chaque relation petit coin préféré
dans Mergui est une ville super avec des
quartiers différents donc chacun aime
bien un quartier donc tout le monde
s'éclate c'est la grande folie mais là
vu que
on a des problèmes d'autorisation de
permis et d'histoire abracadabrantes
l'excitation est moindre on va dire
alors que de chochou se démène avec les
autorités locales pour obtenir le
laisser passer Jacques décide d'emmener
son complice Lucas visiter les derniers
moquens de Mergui
j'accepte les trouveras dans les
faubourgs de la ville loin de leur
culture de nomades
c'est les derniers
[Musique]
j'avais essayé de me faire un quartier
des moquettes que j'ai cherché pendant
des semaines j'ai pas trouvé des
semaines des jours et les derniers que
j'ai trouvé c'est cela voilà et de
maison c'est ceux qui n'ont pas reçu les
autres dans les îles
voilà l'avenir des weekends dans les
sociétés développées plus bas que il y a
pas donc sur les îles ils sont au plus
bas par rapport aux pêcheurs et par
rapport aux armateurs et à terre ils ont
plus bas par rapport même au clodo mais
c'est encore des moquettes c'est pas des
clochards c'est des clochards
même avec si tu attends propre bateau si
tu rentres dans l'archipel il faut que
tu prends une guide officielle du
gouvernement je veux pas aller sans et
c'est lui qui doit faire le rapport
final où on était qu'est-ce qu'on a fait
comme ça pauvre dessous il connaît tout
par cœur mais à chaque fois il se tape
toute ton gamin il connaît surtout les
galères du projet quoi
donc tout de suite on pensait à l'espion
on n'a pas trop bien traité pas mal mais
en ligue nordéen on le laisse donc coin
on parlait pas trop et pendant le voyage
il s'est révélé vraiment une passion
très jolie il sait ce qu'on veut donc
c'était pas besoin de répéter à chaque
fois quand il va avoir une autorité
qu'est-ce qu'on vient faire quoi parce
que moi j'en ai eu un guide une fois on
est allé à ou à Mergui là c'était un
vrai un vrai de vrai quoi
attends on allait aux toilettes il était
derrière la porte
obtenu l'autorisation de ses journées à
Mergui mais un imprévu de taille mais en
péril la fin de l'expédition
le mocan Queen naviguait à travers
l'archipel pendant qu'une tentative de
coup d'état déstabilisée le régime de
Rangoon
les communications dans le pays s'en
trouvent perturbé à un moment où Jacques
a plus que jamais besoin de tous ses
appuis politiques
[Musique]
tous les moyens sont bons pour joindre
la capitale fax radio militaire
téléphone publique rien n'y fait durant
deux jours il est impossible de trouver
un téléphone en état de marche
ces deux façons inattendues comme très
souvent dans ce pays que la situation se
débloque un représentant du ministère du
Transport est enfin en mesure de donner
une réponse
[Musique]
finalement on a donc ce fameux papier
je tiens à montrer 6 mois de travail
qui permet à cbian Discovery et homo Ken
Queen d'aller de naviguer jusqu'à
Rangoon et je pense que ça n'a jamais
été fait après trois jours d'attente le
Moken Queen reprend la mer
tout sont à l'esprit que l'expédition
touche au but ce dernier trajet
représente une véritable première
c'est en pionnier que le cargo et son
équipage rentreront en rade de Rangoon
1000 km plus au nord
aucune mesure de sécurité à Borne est
respectée pour envisager dans les
meilleures conditions ces quatre jours
de mer absence de balises de détresse de
moteur de secours de radio de gilets de
sauvetage
[Musique]
l'activité en mer est centrée sur
l'inventaire des pièces pour
l'exposition chaque objet moquen doit
être répertorié et restera propriété de
l'établissement
pour lui je pense que cette exposition
c'est vraiment clairement la le résultat
des forces des années et des années je
le vois aussi un peu
de tous les recherches commencer par son
père
continué par lui
donc je crois que c'est un peu pour la
famille maintenant on peut le résultat
de tous les efforts de ces derniers 35
ans
[Musique]
Jacques Ivanov a réussi son pari après
avoir sillonné l'archipel de Mergui
durant 25 jours les objets
représentatifs de la culture moquaine
ont été réunis et acheminées jusqu'à
Rangoon
[Musique]
à travers les écrits scientifiques les
livres et les films la défense de la
culture moquenne a toujours été la
priorité de la famille Ivanov
cette exposition contribuera à modifier
le regard du régime birman sur une
minorité en marge
[Musique]
à la veille de l'ouverture probable de
ce pays un tourisme de masse Jacky
vanoff aura fait tout son possible pour
sauvegarder les traces de la culture des
derniers nomades
[Musique]